So TCP has all of these provisions
to deal with packet loss and
other failures.
But why do these ever
happen in the first place?
Why don't networks just be super
reliable, so nothing ever gets dropped?
Well, that's not always an option.
Imagine that you have two machines,
A and
B attached to two
different fast networks.
But those fast networks are connected
by a slow network in the middle.
Like maybe these are two offices
with gigabit ethernet, and
the connection between
them is only 10 megabit.
That's 100 times slower.
Then Host A tries to send a big
pile of data over to Host B,
let's say a gigabyte of data.
Because its own network interface is
very fast, in theory, Host A could
transmit this data as far as its
nearby router, in about 8 seconds.
But that data also has to travel over
this slow link, and because that's 100
times slower, over that 10 megabit
network, it's going to take 13 minutes.
Where does the data have
to live in the mean time?
If Host A were allowed to just push that
big pile of data onto the network, in
order for it to get through, this router
would have to buffer it in memory and
trickle it out over this slow
link over the next 13 minutes.
And meanwhile, nobody else on this
network would be able to send anything.
This link would be saturated,
completely full.
That wouldn't be a very good outcome.
So TCP and
routers don't actually do it that way.
Instead TCP doesn't start
sending data at full blast.
It starts out slowly, only increasing
speed when the other end shows it can
keep up by sending
acknowledgements back.
If packets are dropped, it slows down,
and then gradually it speeds up again.
And routers work with this by dropping
packets if the link they're trying to
send on is too busy.
The result of this is
that the endpoints and
the routers in the middle collaborate to
move data at close to an optimal speed.
But this only works because routers
are willing to drop packets in order to
signal congestion.
And endpoints are willing
to slow down in response.
If the router just let
everything queue up,
the whole connection would
eventually time out.
This is called TCP Congestion Control,
and
that's one of the most important
performance features of TCP.